this is the X2 it was created to fly at
Mach 3 and to address the difficulties
its predecessor the X1 encountered it
featured swept Wings angled backwards to
reduce the effects of shock waves
forming as the plane transitioned from
subsonic to supersonic speeds it pushed
the United States understanding of
Rocket engines 2o helping develop some
of the first turbo pumps to throttle the
rocket motor from 11 kons of thrust to
67 something the X1 couldn't do
its Rocket Motors had one setting on or
off no throttle the X2 set both speed
and altitude records but not without
difficulty shortly after becoming the
first pilot to reach Mach 3 Mel apt
began a banking turn while still above
Mach 3 causing the plane to lose control
violently he managed to eject the
plane's escape capsule but was likely
knocked out in the process and was not
able to deploy his personal parachute in
time